joining me now Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of daily wire.com he was
talking about this today on his podcast
and writing about it as well Ben what do
you make of what's going on so far well
I think that the president has made some
actually well-placed critiques with
regard to for example the spending of
our NATO allies on their own defense and
also with regards to Germany's reliance
on Russian natural gas and the real
question is is that motivated by a
desire to sort of crack NATO or is that
really motivated by a desire to
strengthen NATO because if the idea here
is that we want our NATO allies to be
stronger in their own defense and that
relieves pressure on us and if the idea
is that Germany shouldn't make itself
subject to Russian whim I agree with
that if the idea is that this is sort of
a misdirect that he's just criticizing
these countries because he doesn't like
NATO generally which is the the kind of
nastiest possible read on Trump's
activity then that obviously is bad we
can't tell yet is the answer and I think
that the idea that the United States is
gonna precipitously pull out of NATO I
just don't see that happening I don't
think his advisors are interested in
that happening I'm not sure the
president is interested in that
happening but we're not going to know a
lot until he actually sits down with
Putin and we probably won't know a lot
about the fallout from this for a few
weeks after all of these events are over
yeah very true and I want to talk to you
about the Putin meeting in just a moment
but when you look at this NATO situation
you know I always feel like you have to
kind of peel back and look at what's
actually happening and while they
haven't written the checks yet to fill
that 2% level he left there with an
agreement on their part to do exactly
that so what you've got going into the
Putin meeting is an increase in troops
NATO troops and an increase in by 30 to
40 billion dollars is the estimate to
support those troops that Vladimir
Putin's got to be looking at that across
the border and saying that's formidable
well that's exactly right this is why
it's sort of bizarre to suggest that
Trump was making a pro Putin move by
encouraging all of these countries that
border Russia to increase their defense
spending
I mean if Latvia and Lithuania and
Estonia are all increasing their defense
spending I'm not sure how that benefits
Vladimir Putin the same thing is true if
Trump were able to somehow stop Russia
from importing 70% of Germany's natural
gas I'm not sure how Putin would be
supremely happy with that so that's why
I think that the only people who are
really very upset with Trump are the
ones who are making the most sort of
downcast cynical read of what Trump was
doing here suggesting that all of this
was a front for him
to make an excuse and pull out of NATO
entirely and we haven't seen that happen
yet obviously you made some points today
about about Schroder the former
Chancellor of Germany and the role that
he's playing in this Russia pipeline
deal and I think it's something that
people need to you know sort of go down
to the next layer on and understand can
you explain that sure it's pretty
fascinating Jim Garrity over at National
Review did a good deep dive on this and
what he basically suggests is all the
people who are really upset with
President Trump suggesting the Trump is
colluding with Russia and all the rest
of us
these people are completely ignoring the
fact that the former German Chancellor
Gerhard schröder that he actually is
working with the the Russian state gas
company to build this pipeline from
Russia to Germany and that he's
basically become a Russian agent running
around the EU trying to make deals on
behalf of the Russians when President
Trump criticizes Germany for doing all
of that that that that criticism I think
ought to be well taken in terms of the
Putin meeting what are you watching for
in that and what do you think the
president's real goal is here I think
the president's goal is always
relationship oriented and you can see
this from with everything from Theresa
May and Justin Trudeau to to Kim jong-un
and Putin I think that he'd like to get
along with everyone he says this I don't
think all that complicated I think he
wants to get along with people but the
the policy that comes out the only real
question is is Putin emboldened to try
anything after he meets with Trump if
the answer is no then it's not a major
loss if the answer is yes then Trump has
sent the wrong signals we're not going
to know that until we also realize what
Putin thinks of Trump does he really
think that everything that President
Trump says is all the cards on the table
or does he think okay Trump might be
saying nice things to me but if I make a
move over that line then suddenly Trump
swings into action
yeah yeah it's kind of interesting sort
of ironic really that you've got Justin
Trudeau and Teresa and Mabel saying yeah
you go talk to him you know that yes we
absolutely love the idea of President
Trump going in there and talking to
Putin it seems like maybe they want him
to be the one to sort of be at the front
of the line Ben thank you so much great
to see you as always thanks for being
here tonight it is out you